I was just told we have footage with
video of Donnie Wahlberg and his brother
Mark serenading the family dog when they
were little so I want to see this let's
see this oh
[Music]
[Applause]
we least expected it and he's also part
of the mixtape tour 2022. great guys
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh welcome to the show Rick um
is it true
um your look in that video was a total
fluke uh yeah it's a total mess is what
it is to be honest um I mean it wasn't
styled in any way all those clothes are
my own clothes
um I mean look at the raincoat I mean
come on man it's the middle of July when
we film that video I think but uh yeah
it makes me sweat actually looking at
that video it actually makes me sweat it
brings back great memories and brings
back terrifying memories as well so I
thought it was iconic everyone knows it
and loves it but but um here is a guy
who took Rick Rowland to another level
watch us
this is amazing that's a QR code and
when you scan it well
wow
so this is why I mean what a way to be a
part of Pop Culture forever it's like so
do you do you have a favorite Rick Roll
uh favorite Rick Roll I mean so many
people have done so many crazy things
with that thing uh my ultimate ultimate
favorite favorite I think is I was told
that the uh the White House was Rick
Rolled everybody on staff and Obama was
the president at the time so even he got
Rick Rolled that day in an email that
everybody got so I kind of thought that
was amazing but I mean there's just been
some crazy ones over the time to be
honest it's the song that keeps giving
that's the way I look at it oh my God
did you did you see Ted lat do you watch
Ted lasso
boss I'm a massive fan oh my gosh I love
it and then use your song there too
that's amazing I just didn't know if you
saw that episode
no it's it's just unbelievable and and
uh Hannah who sang the tune as well
she's a great great singer and it kind
of brought a tear to my eye to be honest
because like I say a lot of people have
done some fun things with with that
they've even tattooed themselves
um but um but I think to see somebody do
it so emotionally that song you know
what I mean it can turn it on yeah it's
just incredible so yeah oh man she just
literally Hannah was just on the show
and I'm a fan for life I loved her from
Ted lasso but in person she's even just
more of a joy I love her
[Music]
thank you